[Music]
hey this is episode
i don't even know anymore of
[Music]
congratulations
yeah yeah yeah dude it's uh uh
another episode you know um
uh whoops stay on page here i gotta i
almost clicked out of the whole [ __ ]
thing
timing how long i'm supposed to do it
because we're flying by the seat of our
pants on this episode i'll tell you but
i actually i will say this it's not that
we're flying by the seat of our pants
but it's that it's
uh it's [ __ ] 10 46
right now doing this so this is a late
night one so you never know sometimes
they go off the rails
and off the rails uh can be a good thing
but it can also be a [ __ ] dangerous
thing for me as i've learned in the last
few months
um anyway i
uh i do you know you do you [ __ ]
self-reflect man you do
you live life you don't think you stop
you [ __ ] think
and you figure it out
uh if you know what's good for you
anyway
uh one of the things i [ __ ] figured
out is
and and check this [ __ ] out for real
your boy
and by your boy i mean me can cut his
own [ __ ] hair
and i can do it all the day as long and
i can do it
like the dickens and i can do it better
than the [ __ ] people who cut hair
sorry the people who cut hair
i appreciate you i enjoyed sitting in
your hair in your chairs for
all of the [ __ ] years i even enjoyed
getting my haircut when i was a kid from
that guy named tony
that would [ __ ] my dad would bring
him
and asked my dad once while he was
cutting the back of my hair you want a
rattle
and i s and my dad said huh and he said
you want to retail
and my dad said no and i didn't know
what the hell tony was [ __ ] saying
and then when i got home i asked dad
hey dad what the [ __ ] did that guy say
and he said do you want
to for me to cut a [ __ ] rat tail in
your son's head
hey tony no i was eight
you want a tail and then i rewound it in
my head you know how you can do that i
rounded it in my head
and and i realized she said you want to
retail do you want to retail
dude do you want to retail
uh anyway dude i cut my own hair man and
it is [ __ ]
good and i'm i'm i'm the kind of guy if
i suck at something
i will tell you dude like um
splitting atoms
i can't do that you know but i can
[ __ ] cut my own hair or or not being
selfish
i'm bad at that but i'm working on it
dude and i'm better now
than i was you know i'm not doing all
the selfish things i'm [ __ ] trying to
live for other people and i have a
[ __ ] son now so anyway my point is i
could cut my own hair
and it [ __ ] looks banging dude did
you know that oh you do now man
because you could see me and i look look
at what i take this off dude
forget it it gets a little okay so
here's the thing though
i cut it and when i cut it by the way
the best thing about cutting your own
hair
and this is for the guys because i don't
think girls can do that [ __ ] i mean that
you can do it of course equal
opportunity i get it
i don't want to get cancelled again but
my point
is that girls shouldn't cut their own
hair because girls have a lot of hair
and girls hair is like an outfit you
know what i mean
like girls will be like what kind of
hair do i want today and you'll be like
oh you can just change like you're a
[ __ ]
action figure but girls can just cut
their [ __ ]
or no i'm sorry i cut their [ __ ] but
they could put it up they could put it
down they could put it sideways they
could do a beehive they could put a
little house in it and a bird can land
in it
they can do whatever the [ __ ] they want
and change the whole getup
guys pretty much just have standard hair
so what you can do as a guy is just
[ __ ] take your time
you know what i'm talking about girls
bunch up their hair getting done
all in [ __ ] well i don't know my
fiance will be like i'm going to get my
hair
hair done i'm like really why are you
bringing a [ __ ] sleeping bag she's
like
it takes three days you know you're so
[ __ ] i
girls will wake up at [ __ ] oh dark 30
and go to get their hair cut and come
back
after [ __ ] dinner time and they're
like do you like it and it looks
exactly the same you know oh yeah yeah
yeah it's good yes
it's a little darker right it's blonder
uh so i meant blunder
right it's blonder and you cut it
shorter right yes
of course because why would how could
you get it longer well you have
extension you have extensions oh okay
cool
so extensions and blonder great um
how about the fact that you can go and
sit in a chair and just make your hair
longer too that's
that's that's not scientifically
possible but girls made it possible and
so
um so guys you could spread that
[ __ ] three hours out you know when i
would go get my hair cut they would do
it in like 30 minutes
or sometimes if i got chatty you know
they they'd like your boy's personality
and it would take 50 to 60 minutes right
um with tony though was just get in
cut it get out right you want a retail
no thank you
here's 16 bye
dad what do you say yes if you wanted a
rat tail let's never go back to him
again so
i um i spread it out dude
i do a little [ __ ] snip here and a
little snip there dude i do a little
snip here little snip there
i go top snip side snip snip did i
[ __ ] make one side longer than the
other i pull it out
oh it's a little longer snip snip i go
have a bite come back
catch myself in the mirror wait a second
do a little back track
grab the [ __ ] scissors nearby i keep
the scissors near every mirror snip snip
snip
at the end of all of it which is like
you know i do this maybe every month and
a half and it takes [ __ ] four days to
cut hair
i look i look really good you know uh
from the front you know what i'm talking
about look really good from the front
because
i realized i i saw a picture of me from
behind me
and the [ __ ] just looks like the back of
a [ __ ] skunk's ass because i
it dude it pops i didn't re i forgot not
that i forgot to cut the back but i
thought i was getting it you know
it's really hard to cut the back of your
hair unless you're [ __ ] you can't
hold the mirror and look in the mirror
at the other mirror and have the
scissors i thought you could but who
holds the [ __ ] hair
and i won't let kristen help because
then i didn't do it myself do you
understand what i'm saying
so your boy cuts his own hair and this
is how it looks and no
disrespect to all the people who [ __ ]
i sat in your chair but
i know my hair better dude you know when
you're done [ __ ] if you're a guy cut
your own hair i heard george clooney did
it
probably 20 years ago and i always
thought about that
and now i'm [ __ ] i swear to god i'm
like basically george clooney in that in
that area
i'm drinking coffee uh at 10 48 at night
and i can drink coffee late at night and
then conk out um but
yeah it doesn't really affect me and
it's annoying when people say that
because they're always trying to impress
you when they say that but i'm not
trying to impress you
what i'm trying to say is if i drink
celsius celsius fit or celsius live fit
or celsius heat
i'm off the rails i'm like sonic the
hedgehog looking for coins man i'm and
i'm
nuts when i do it i'm nuts and that's
when i work out i take a celsius heat
and then i start working out
and dude my back when i [ __ ] work my
back out and i check myself in the
mirror it looks like i'm just storing
captain america's shield
ready for battle casually you know he
wears it on the back i don't know if you
know that
he's not always [ __ ] ready for battle
but he's got it on his back
i'm like a turtle um
yeah so i cut my own hair and uh and
that's just basically how it's to be now
until i die
i'll i'll probably lose it you know i
thought i was thinning a little bit and
then i realized
it doesn't matter at all who gives a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
my dad would always say to me when i was
a kid you know some guys go bald that's
the only thing you have to worry about
who cares if you go bald just you go
bald and i was like yeah
and i thought maybe that's not right and
then i realized who gives a [ __ ] [ __ ]
man
just get your family wife the [ __ ] up
have a few kids and
go bald it's better then you don't have
to worry about it that's the only thing
a [ __ ] guy has to worry about
unless you're famous um so uh but yeah
so i
i cut my own hair um
and uh i felt a little rusty i didn't
know if i felt rusty or what when i was
doing my podcast
um you know
every now and then i'll go on a run and
i'll forget something and i'll be like
what was i going to talk about and i
wonder if that would be me being rusty
because i tell you what man over the
past however many months i have not felt
funny dude
you know how to make someone not feel
funny
[ __ ] bash him online so so much
you take a thick skin [ __ ] that
thought he built up some [ __ ]
over the bomb years of stand up when you
just bomb and you're like well i'm
strong i don't care what people say
about me and then you have
the whole world saying something about
you and you're like okay i was
i thought i was strong but instead i'll
die
instead i'll die i kept thinking [ __ ]
every time i would catch something
online or my buddy said oh i saw this
about you or whatever i had that [ __ ]
that meme
guess i'll die now that old guy with the
[ __ ] red turtleneck
guess i'll die that was me
um but yeah so so you just don't feel
funny man
i'm on the group test texts trying to
[ __ ] do jokes with my buddies i'm
like nah that's not working
i don't do i don't know i don't i don't
do twitter or [ __ ]
[ __ ] anymore i don't do the i didn't do
the podcast so i was just like let me
just do a funny voice note
and i was just on my of it [ __ ] me up
and then and then
now i feel you know doing my podcast i
didn't know if it was rusty or not
i heard [ __ ] pilots are crashing
because they're not even
they don't fly anymore because of the
covet [ __ ] they're like getting all laid
off and not used for months and then
they're like yeah
oh a job great showing up to the [ __ ]
cockpit all drunk didn't think they had
to do it
mask hanging off their ear i'm ready
wrong hat on
it's hey where's your pilot's cap
is that it pulls it off as a [ __ ]
tampa bay
uh uh it's a [ __ ] devil raised hat
sorry i got the wrong hat anyway [ __ ]
what's up okay
wheels up what is up
um and they're crashing and doing like
all sorts of [ __ ] up [ __ ] man
i don't know man i don't know if i would
take a flight now
i don't i don't want to be going
anywhere because i'm scared of a little
bit of covid and here's the other thing
too man i'm not scared of dying i don't
want to get sick dude
i'd rather just chill and wait the [ __ ]
out i don't want to get sick man
people are like oh you're scared of
covid bro i don't want the flu i don't
want a cold
i just don't want to feel [ __ ] shitty
um yeah so
my uh what happened with my son today
what happened with my son today callie's
cute he still won't say ball i tell him
to say ball he won't say ball
but you know he waves at
everybody i told you that already but
also he'll give the ball
to one of our one of our dogs one of our
shitty dogs he'll give the ball to one
of our shitty
dogs and our dog will be like is is this
okay like he's looking at me
can i take this from the new guy and and
cal
kelly's just like you know
he he doesn't even know what he's doing
but he's like this is a thing that you
can do in life and they'll hand the ball
to the
[ __ ] to our one of our shitty dogs
and our shitty dog will just be like
it's cool it's like the guy who's going
for seconds at like a free buffet
just like is did everyone got their
everyone got their stuff right it's
gonna go to waste
okay see you later and then runs off and
pisses on the [ __ ] corner of the
couch
our dogs won't stop pissing on the
corner couch really cool uh i'm gonna
[ __ ] piss on how about this dude i'm
gonna piss on the corner of the couch to
[ __ ] show those dogs that that's my
place
speaking of which dude i figured out
something man
this is how [ __ ] up i am and i don't
mean this in a cute way and by the way
this is how [ __ ] up i am and i'm only
saying this how [ __ ] up i am because
kristen is like you're so [ __ ] up i'm
not [ __ ] up i think i'm not [ __ ] up
because of this ever since i turned 40
which was not too long ago because i'm
very young still
all right i'm squeaking into four and
four i've been i'm 40 i've been 40 for
i'm almost
i'm almost 41 okay ever since i turned
i i have to wake up in the middle of the
night to pee okay
fine whatever joke about how i'm an old
guy it's all good but it happened
pretty much the day i turned 40. all of
a sudden
sometimes i wake up at [ __ ] 5 a.m
sometimes i wake up at 7 30 a.m
which is the most annoying because i
have to because i'm like should i just
stay up but no
i [ __ ] try to conk out till 9 30 10
right
because the kid sleeps till [ __ ] dude
that kid will sleep he's just like a
[ __ ]
it's like he's on xanax or something i
think my kid is [ __ ]
just partying in his crib do you know
what i mean
like dude the kid sleeps so late it's
weird um
anyway yeah i had one of my group
meetings that i had to [ __ ] go to
in the morning and one of the guy and i
was like i can't i ca sorry i didn't
make it cause i overslept and he's
it's at nine and he's like what do you
mean it's [ __ ] nine he's like don't
you have a
[ __ ] eight month old whatever he was
back then and i was like yeah and i felt
like i was lying
i felt i felt like i was like when i
used to [ __ ] cheat i'm like well no
he's okay
i was sleeping and it's all good because
of the [ __ ]
i he sleeps late look and i took a
screenshot of him sleeping on the
[ __ ] when he woke up on the nan it
and i sent it over i'm like
i i just i anyway
um so yeah so i
figured this out so i used to i woke up
at i used to
i know i wake up sometimes 7 30
sometimes i wake up at 5 00 sometimes i
wake up at 3 30. sometimes 1
2 1 20 i'll wake up i'll fall asleep at
midnight and at 1 20 i'll wake up
and i'll be like i got to pee so [ __ ]
bad and i'm like i just
peed at 12 11 59 a peek and i started to
sleep at 120 i pee so i'm mad now
because i got to wake up to piss
right and i'm so pissed off and i did
the thing where i was like [ __ ] it i'm
gonna go just back to sleep
and i'm just gonna have to pee and sleep
through it
that's my penance you know my body's
changing now
[ __ ] you body i got this i'm going to
stay asleep
and then go back to sleep sure enough i
couldn't do it because you know when you
got to pee you got to pee
so i would wake up i would go pee wake
up
trying to turn the light on find the
toilet go back by the time i come back
my heart's beating because i'm mad as
[ __ ] cause now i'm a guy that wakes up
in the middle of night to be
right so
now i'm like what am i gonna do because
my body is betraying me do you
understand me
so i i ordered on amit because i went i
wanted to go get him but i was like
maybe i shouldn't go get him because if
i go out in public someone might take a
picture and be like hey i spotted chris
lee i haven't seen him in a long time
and look what he's buying so instead i
[ __ ] got it sent
from amazon and they showed up to the
house i opened up the box
and my girl said what's that and i said
well kristin
they're depends and i got a whole mess
of them dude
and i got smalls i know you're probably
thinking but he's not small
i'm not small but i am small for a 90
year old
okay your boy where smalls depends so
dude i
got them and i [ __ ] i tonight is the
first night
i'm gonna wear those [ __ ] and
i'm gonna piss the bed dude
i'm gonna piss the bed and i win body
i win my body betrayed me well guess
what
dude i'm gonna use my mind to trump my
body so now
my body and my mind are both back on my
side i win
i figured it out i'm elon musk of
pissing pants
go ahead [ __ ] take cars to space
figure out how to make hoverboards
without people dying
i figured out how to piss the bed in a
cool fashion
as a 40 year old and i'll tell you what
too
[Music]
i realized this because once when i was
30 as a joke somebody got me a bunch of
depends
and i went hahaha very funny and i
stored them off to the side and i didn't
throw them away and i didn't know why
but a few months later my buddy was over
and he was like why do you have the pens
and i told him the story of it somebody
made a joke and then [ __ ] bought me
the depends and i paused
i realized why the [ __ ] haven't i not
tried this so i put the depends on when
i was 30
and i pissed now i'm assuming
mostly all of my listeners have never
pissed and depends
well when you piss and depends
it's like your dick coughs liquid
isn't even around it's not like
oh so it absorbs the liquid it's like no
it's so it it's it's like the [ __ ]
liquid
just comes out as
it's amazing the diaper gets heavy and
it's a little warm
but it does not feel like liquid so i
can't wait to piss the bed tonight and
kristen is like what the [ __ ] i don't
want to you know
[Music]
my fiance is like you're going to just
piss the bed and i'm like yup
and guess what dude i'm not this is not
negotiable because my body betrayed me
you should be on my team are you on my
team are you my body's team
so she's like all right she rolls her
eyes she's like you better not get
pissed on the bed i'm not going to get
pissed off a bit because i pissed i used
to depends when i was 30.
i tried it they don't even leak down the
leg dude i'm not bullshitting you man
this is not a [ __ ] comedy bit you
piss and depends it's like you're not
pissing
so um i'm gonna do it dude
my body ain't [ __ ] dude i tell my body
what goes on
it's your body be in control of your
body if you can't do it physically
then get depends and make sure you
[ __ ] can handle your business get
whatever contraption you need to do to
make your body do it
dude there's guys out there that can't
walk they're sitting in wheelchairs why
the [ __ ] can i use depends
i swear to god i'm gonna [ __ ] try you
know what i'm gonna show up with one of
those
i'm gonna get one of those handicap
stickers for the [ __ ] car and i'm
gonna roll out and i'm gonna look all
fit and able-bodied people go what's
wrong with that i'd be like i pissed the
middle of the night i got depends when i
sleep
and like okay i don't think that that
that's why you get this spot close to
the pizza hut
that's why you get this closer spot to
the pizza hut yup
cause i figured it out dude i'm the elon
musk of pissing pants
um yeah dude
and i'm so dead serious and i'm excited
to do it
dude i can't wait to do it
i'll [ __ ] in them yeah
yeah i will
would i [ __ ] them if i was a if i
was shitty i'd be like depends but
that's not funny so i won't say it but
i'll say i won't say it so you know i
thought of it
yeah dude why doesn't [ __ ] depends
sponsor this podcast oh yeah
oh yeah that's right
hey depends
you want a 40 year old helping you out
with sales why don't you sponsor this
podcast
oh yeah dude i forgot
i i forgot
some people just watch like to watch the
world burn
oh [ __ ] kick his [ __ ] teeth and kick
his
[ __ ] teeth in
um for [ __ ] sake
ah [ __ ] ah [ __ ]
god thank god for this fight
the governor's back i got my
my [ __ ] shirt i haven't worn this
shirt in so long it's my orange shirt
that i used to talk about in my act
my favorite [ __ ] orange shirt and
it's back we're back in business dude
that's crystalia with his [ __ ]
favorite orange shirt and the poofy hair
because he can't get to the back of it
hell yeah dude
yo is that crystalia or a bird of
paradise
[ __ ] that dude i'm just trying to get
the hair to where i look like a bird of
paradise
man um yeah
anyway dude it hurt when i was punching
my own hand um
um um
bubble gup guppy guppy guppies
bubble bubble guppies guppies bubble
guppies dude hey
[ __ ] jingle guy try harder you know
just bubble bubble bubble guppy guppy
guppies over and over again just try
harder dude
guy probably makes [ __ ] 20 grand a
jingle how about just bubble bubble
bubble guppy guppy guppies over and over
again cool
cool that's cool yeah how about guppies
over and over again didn't i used to
have this bubble bubble
guppy guppy cubbies over and over again
yeah cool thank you very much
dude
yeah man oh remember when tom cruise got
mad it wasn't even as good as when
christian bale got mad that's it don't
want to talk about it
next i don't give a [ __ ] i'll talk about
what i want to yes
dude don't turn me back into old chris
i'm new chris now okay that's for real
i gotta do podcast mode chris but still
new chris
oh the super bowl i saw that
tom brady is just i love by the way dude
love him don't care don't care who he
voted for love him
don't care who he's voted for love him
um the guy threw the [ __ ] trophy from
one boat to another boat
love that dude he is my hero not because
he won 119 super bowls because he took
the trophy
and threw it to a [ __ ] guy named rob
gronkowski on another boat
you know rob gronkowski that name is the
most
[ __ ] naming name
uh but yeah and then and then what's his
name and then he was drunk
uh tom brady does that and also
dude he's 43 and also
i love him there was a female ref for
the first time ever in the super bowl
which i don't know why there's not more
female refs only there should only be
female rest people are like
this marks the day in history females
she was the first female in the nfl and
she's finally getting her
dude fire all the men have women in
there you know why
because women are so good at being like
you know what you know what
actually okay yeah but you know what
[ __ ] get kristen in there dude get my
[ __ ] fianc get my wifey in there get
her
in there are you kidding me dude the
score would be zero
negative three no take
take points off because you weren't you
weren't [ __ ] paying attention to what
i said
you can't lose yes mark it down mark it
[ __ ] down
mark it down in her little [ __ ]
white and black stripes do it
how many of you guys put the dishes in
the dishwasher
how many on the team what does it have
to how [ __ ] many
okay um i don't know i think nine of us
take some a few points off
take a few points off you're supposed to
throw a flight you want a [ __ ] flag
here's a [ __ ] here's a [ __ ] flag
there take it take the [ __ ] flag take
it pick it up
put in the dishwasher take the flag and
put in the [ __ ] dishwasher
no safety
give him a safety please give him a
[ __ ] safety
do you know what a safety is it makes
you lose points
give him a [ __ ] safety tom bradshaw
give tom bradshaw a [ __ ] safety
it's it's brady it's tom brady i don't
give a [ __ ] what it is that's two first
names
give it to tom bradshaw
and put it in your [ __ ] and and make
sure that gisele bundchen is happy when
you go home
isn't a bunch in a [ __ ] like siamese
uh warrior
i don't know actually you know what
dude every it's so also like dude
with the [ __ ] the mask wearing
i don't even wear i wear a i wear a
richard nixon mask
so then when people are like sir you
need to have a mask
you need to have a mask and you need to
have a mask oh
yeah okay cool i'll be right back and
then i come back with a [ __ ] richard
nixon mask on and i say
i'd like a [ __ ] iced americano and
everyone hits the deck
what sir just take it and leave
what the [ __ ] are you talking about sir
take the money in the cash register i'm
not here to rob the place
i'm here to be covet friendly
can i have a nice america no in the
meantime the only thing in that mask
that's open
is the [ __ ] mouth because you have to
breathe
i love that [ __ ] how kids have to wear
the [ __ ] masks
with and it and it looks like the mask
but there's like a [ __ ] slit for the
mouth
and you gotta like and it's like for
breathing it's like dude you could
breathe anyway dude you don't need to
put a [ __ ] slit in there
when i was a kid it would always piss me
off i'd have like the coolest outfit i
was like pee
herman and killing it but there was like
a slit for the mouth and you just look
like someone
would walk by and put a [ __ ] coin in
it
um
christmas was cool with the kid with
with with callie we we
um that's another thing that i tried to
you know every year i had pictures with
santa as a kid
up until i was 37 and um i would go and
i would be sitting on the
no up until i was however old i [ __ ]
i i would complain with my to my mom so
many different times i'd be like i don't
want to do it anymore she'd be like
please it's the last year
and i did it till i was way too old and
like [ __ ] dockers and a guy and a
[ __ ] j
crew shirt and um
and uh and so i
uh they so i i was like i want to take
calvin to the [ __ ] santa but we can't
because of covid
and there were no richard nixon masks
that were small enough to fit over his
face
so to keep him safe and so i uh so i
went to go take
i was like what are we gonna do and i
was like i'm gonna [ __ ] dress up as
santa
i don't give a [ __ ] i'll dress up as
santa i'll walk in the room
ha-ha-ho-in put a pillow in my tummy
and just pick him up and [ __ ] text
him we'll take some pictures and that'll
be the first one and we'll remember oh
remember coven remember when he was a
kid
when he was one years old his first
christmas dad was santa
that's the [ __ ] dude um
so i wanted to do that and uh
i was like what size what can we get
because we realized it too late
and kristen was like oh i i got one
i was like really christmas is six days
away yeah
she said but it's [ __ ] xxl
and i'm like it's triple xl i'm a
[ __ ] you know your boy
i don't wanna your boy's lean though you
know it's like
yeah if you're gonna like what letter do
i look like v
do you know what i'm talking about and
so
i'm like all right she's like don't
worry i can sew it if it's too big
she's good with that [ __ ] but it's so
annoying too because it [ __ ]
it doesn't work sometimes she'll be like
i get a new piece of furniture and i'm
like really
yeah and then it shows up and it's like
19 feet by 19 feet and i'm like what the
[ __ ] are we gonna do like this
she's like i guess i guess we're gonna
have to put it on the only wall we need
to put it on
that that's big enough like did you
measure it and she's like no
you eat a chip walk away like it's no
[ __ ] big deal
and i'm sitting there fuming like some
guy in a sitcom
i used to do sitcoms and so um
so anyway she was gonna show the thing
it came
it was actually it was too big and she
showed it nice she did it good
right and we did it and
uh we put cal we put cal
we put calvin in the uh thing waiting
for santa
and you know how i told you in the last
podcast
calvin only has um uh
met nine people you know
because of covid and he met santa that
day
you know what i'm talking about but yeah
cali met santa claus
and so uh so
santa came in and said ho ho ho and this
is this is this is my son
hello have you been a good boy and this
is him
did somebody be a good and i got a sack
nothing's in it but he doesn't know you
know
i put the sack down hello and my mom's
like what the [ __ ] i didn't know i was
gonna do i surprised everybody i think i
think honestly some of my family thought
santa was really there and um
and i show up and and and kelly was just
sitting there watching santa
and um and i pick them up i put them on
my
knee as soon as i put them on my knee
ah it just starts crying we took three
four pictures real quick i'll post them
on instagram you know
he's so cute but he was crying he never
cries dude this kid is easy as [ __ ]
this kid's cool man he never cries he
cried when i
when he you know when he sits on santa's
lap and then when he bonks his head
every now and then but sometimes dude
he'll just [ __ ] he'll do like that
good acting cry where he just like lets
it out a little bit
where it's like he'll go bonk and we're
like oh and we brace for impact and then
we will we try to act chill you know
because you don't want to be like oh no
because then it's like well what
happened
you know so we do we're just like so so
i try to act like real cool when he hits
his head so he doesn't cry he'll hit his
head and i'll like grab a top hat and
just throw it on and start flipping a
coin
and i'd be like hey cat y'all right
what's going on then i'll just wait and
see what happens in my [ __ ]
and so he uh he'll start he'll and you
know he'll cry but he'll do that good
acting cry where he'll just go like
and then just move on dude start
watching bubble guppies
um yeah the kid doesn't cry man
i do
every day every day i cry um
yeah so yeah
i do i cry every day at least once
that's how it is when you're in recovery
um
and realizing stuff about yourself
and i'm gonna brown
[Music]
sex because you
that's what it is when you're in
recovery
because you're [ __ ] home you sex you
feel like you're inadequate
because something happened to you
probably when you were a kid
and you had micro aggressions on you
brown brown brown they call
[Music]
everybody's [ __ ] up but when you
realize how [ __ ] up
you are
you cry at least once a day
sometimes you cry in the car pro
sometimes you cry at home
sometimes you say bye to your fiance
that you cheated on
and then you [ __ ] get in the car and
cry
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] dude
what was it talking about what even was
i talking about
i don't even remember dude wow
we derail we derail but
uh anyway yeah so i [ __ ] yeah call
cow he cried he doesn't cry his dad
cries more than him
um come on catch up cal
uh yeah so i've been [ __ ] trying to
you know figure out who i really am and
what to do and [ __ ]
you i [ __ ] hated everything you know
old chris used to [ __ ] just
never do
never want to do [ __ ] you know never
want to do [ __ ]
i just wouldn't i'd want to [ __ ]
drink coffee
uh you know message women
and [ __ ] work out and do stand up
that was it that was my life you know
and um now i gotta do other [ __ ]
you know i gotta [ __ ] expand my
horizons i gotta expand my [ __ ]
horizons dude
i used to think expanding horizons were
boring man i would make up all these
[ __ ] ideas and compartmentalize about
how [ __ ] stupid it was that people
thought they were open-minded and [ __ ]
i was such a [ __ ] bonehead [ __ ]
but um yeah
so my uh
one day i was just like let's do a
[ __ ] puzzle
and we did a puzzle with uh of
of santa and that was fun as [ __ ] man
you ever do a puzzle
and i realized that [ __ ] it dude
i'm all in this boring life i'm all
in i'm a dad with a kid who does a
puzzle
and i [ __ ] you know
i sit i've got my thing that i do
i need to get a chair like a [ __ ]
dad's in his chair if you need him
that's what i need
but yeah man i'm all in this boring life
i do puzzles man
i [ __ ] with puzzles man hardcore
i did one of paris i did one of another
city i didn't even really know what it
was because i'm not really that cultured
what if i end up going there one day and
i don't even realize it and i
look out and i'm on vacation when i'm
like 90 years old
wearing my depends this time in the
daytime and i look and i'm like whoa
wait a second i
i did a puzzle i did a puzzle
like this once didn't i darling
the thing about this podcast is it's
nice to do it's nice i have it man
you know it's like it's nice that i have
it
for me i guess
um i don't know i don't know
uh what else can i talk about i have a
it's really cool you know what's [ __ ]
awesome though is that my contacts
are uh absolutely [ __ ] going bonkers
in my eye and i can't see anything
um oh dude you guys oh dude
i want hey buy dodge coin doge
dodge coin what is it dogecoin dogacoin
i don't know
buy it so it goes up i bought some you
know
and i wanted it to make more money bro
that's the thing about me is the [ __ ]
that i [ __ ] get into i get into
dude yeah that's why
yeah that's why i i am where i am but i
[ __ ] dude i
i i'm into stocks now dude i got some
tesla
not much you know but um i still look at
it every day and all the time i look at
it and it [ __ ] will go up like one
tenth of a [ __ ] cent and i'm just
like hell yeah dude
let's get that dope let's see where it
is now dude let's see where it is now
uh let's see where it is now
see stocks are now let's see where do
crate went down i always [ __ ] dude my
buddy told me to get
dogecoin and i got it and it [ __ ]
went down lost like a hundred dollars
it's all good though um
so i lost a hundred dollars on stonks
but it is what it is dude it's dangerous
game
stocks they just game that stocks i'm
practically i'm in boiler room i'm in
that movie boiler room
um and bitcoin's crazy right
i can't believe these [ __ ]
cryptocurrencies
i've never said that word until right
now um
oh you know what happened my [ __ ]
remember the dog that my mom thought got
[ __ ] lenny
remember she i told you this on the
podcast before when she was like oh
my brother would pet anytime someone
would pet lenny on his butt
lenny would go like and my mom would and
my mom my mom would literally
she would literally she literally said
you know why that he does you know why i
think he does that
and we said what he said i think
somebody but [ __ ] him
that's what my mom said
to the family at dinner
i think somebody [ __ ] him my mom
said that
okay and i know i've said this before on
the podcast
but i need to say that again
well apparently it served lenny well
that rough upbringing getting [ __ ]
and whatnot
by the way i was like you mean like a
dog
[ __ ] would like [ __ ] lenny
and my mom said no i think
like his previous owner
my mom
because my brother pet lenny
and lenny went my
mom my human mom
jumped skyrocketed to the
conclusion that the dog
used to have an owner that would butt
[ __ ] him on a regular basis
okay okay
so that's a that's a real thing so that
happened at dinner
okay so that dog apparently
growing up growing up rough
dude he got attacked by a coyote
and lenny up apparently
went back into his [ __ ]
enough's enough you know what i mean i
won't take it anymore
and bit the [ __ ] tail
off of the coyote and the coyote ran
away
lenny what coyote get off of me
get off of me raj you know what i mean
or whatever the [ __ ] is previous
just a flashback and bit the tail off
the coyote my dad saw the coyote running
away with no tama that's like what the
[ __ ]
and lenny was sitting there just like
wheezing and
puncture wounds but with that [ __ ]
coyote tail
and my brother said i want that
took the tail and is gonna frame it my
whole family's
crazy
okay and so lenny's
okay now he was wobbling dude
like this just [ __ ] wobbling back and
my butt my dad was just like oh
bro so upset man
uh yeah yeah so lenny's okay now
so whatever happened to lenny in the
past whatever it was whatever made him
growl because my brother pet him on the
back
uh served him well against that coyote
so here's to lenny huh
it's tough when a [ __ ] dog you don't
think about it
like my dogs basically just [ __ ] and
piss i don't even really know they're
there a lot of the time like i'm like
wait a second
but they ran away once and i was [ __ ]
man
like you take them for granted because
they're just around and you get mad when
they piss on the [ __ ] couch
or or sn or snap at you you know you're
like hey hey
you got it good
um and uh yeah so [ __ ]
they uh they ran away once and i was
calling out for them all [ __ ] night
dude
and it was just it's brutal man it sucks
we found them they came back like they
went on [ __ ] vacation
they were just like i left the gate open
and they just went
and then i realized like an hour later
and then they [ __ ] just
came back dude you know how good dogs
have to have it if they just [ __ ]
come back
that's outside that's their world
they're wolves dogs are wolves
that are dogs now and they just left
then came back
um yeah so and then we found another one
cenzo you know that trash dog that i
talk about
um and
uh and yeah and and uh he's fat as [ __ ]
now
because we fed him we picked him up in
like panorama city she was at a target
for some [ __ ] reason in panorama city
and she was like there's a dog and i was
like oh just bring it here
did the [ __ ] dog didn't do [ __ ] for
three weeks and then just started
barking and never
still barking right now and uh he's fat
now dude he was all skinny and emaciated
and then we took him and he [ __ ] that
kid that [ __ ] dog will just grab
food so quickly dude he's like a
magician
he's like a [ __ ] now you see it now
you don't you're like where is my burger
and then you see
chen's just like [ __ ] hanging over to
the side just like
burping and [ __ ] the burger out on
your couch
dude chen's [ __ ] sucks man
he sucks man i don't even know what kind
of dog he is you know when you find a
dog and you're like not a purebred
you're like what
what's going on here man
we gotta we're doing a dna test on him
though and we we think he's a little bit
chihuahua and part
martian um
and he sleeps like [ __ ] with his arm
up over his
thing like he's dracula
the whole thing pisses me off we have
too many dogs dude and we have a kid too
so we have like five
[ __ ] things going on i'm just gonna
come home once with a parrot
chris is gonna be like why do you and
i'll be like well you keep bringing [ __ ]
home
have a parrot [ __ ] it
the parrot flies away [ __ ] it
the parrot she's upset
flying by me what what's she mad about
you move the lamp
wrong please
what are you doing
the parrot does what [ __ ] what cal
does
[Laughter]
dude cali
he tries to talk and just
parrot flying by
he can't talk yet he won't say ball
i feel like he's [ __ ] with me at this
point he's he's one
you know what i mean talk you're one
say some [ __ ] already how do you feel
it's been a year
he's [ __ ] with me at this point he's
like i'm gonna see how long i can ride
out this not talking [ __ ] and have them
just be [ __ ] catering to my every
need
you know what i'm talking about how long
how do you feel it's been a year
do you feel good has your tummy ever
ached
what's going on are you cr you bit his
tongue the other day
does it hurt a lot or a little tell your
dad dude
i'm your [ __ ] dad talk
imagine i did that to him jesus christ
is the man [ __ ] up you know man boy you
need to man up
i'm old school you need to rub some
[ __ ] dirt on it boy
um nah i'm gonna teach my [ __ ] son
feelings dude i'm gonna teach him by the
way he's already seen his dad cry
[ __ ] 468 times but i'm gonna teach
him feelings like a [ __ ]
i'm gonna teach him it's okay to cry
while i'm crying
because of some [ __ ] you know you know
it's okay to cry
see your dad does it and he's just gonna
think [ __ ]
you're a [ __ ] what if that was those
were his first words man i'd give him a
trophy
um i love him so much man
it's crazy that he could prob he'll be
able to [ __ ]
watch this one day um if you are
watching this i love you
um so much man
yeah um so yeah
i don't know i guess that's it dude i
don't need to [ __ ] talk about it
anything
you know i don't need to make this
podcast as long it's been 50 minutes i
don't need to do it any longer than that
i could do whatever i want i guess
right sometimes i feel like it needs to
be an hour but i'm just getting back
into the swing of things you know just
getting back into the swing of things
and feeling it out maybe the next one
will be an hour i don't know when i'm
going to start doing the [ __ ] patreon
thing
i don't know if i am or not man right
now
what i want to do is what i want to do
and i i'm just on my [ __ ] path
of also just
i'm focused on my family even still and
i'm focused on my recovery even still
um because that's how it needs to be um
but i don't know thanks for listening
uh that's it dude i appreciate you
listening and that's congratulations and
remember
all right guys take care
thank you